okay guys
okay guys um
what do you want me to react to so i'm
gonna do it live
oh my god my dog keeps farting that is
literally disgusting ellie
um okay
i hit 20 000 subscribers this month
which is kind of crazy i feel like i've
actually barely posted i've just posted
reels
um sorry i have you guys's
comment section pulled up now
so this is an interesting poll
if you had to guess what is the average
body count for a 27 year old in 2021
which is the average age of first
marriage
so i was actually going
to ask um
i was actually gonna ask for women um
but i forgot to like clarify this but
when you think about it
the average you would think would be the
same for both because
like
all the guys
like
all the guys with crazy body counts
like wouldn't it be equal
i don't know if it's like oh my gosh i'm
not good with math but anyways
um thirty percent said between zero and
ten
ten to twenty percent or ten or thirty
percent between ten and twenty
fifteen percent percent twenty to thirty
so
if we combined these two
10 20
34 the highest percentage believe that
it's over 20 plus bodies
and
37 percent believe it's below 10
50
and about 70 believe it's over 10.
huh interesting
um
okay guys give me something to react to
let me listen and make sure this sounds
okay on this
section pulled up
oh my gosh what is the
what is that buzzing noise i wonder if i
can turn it off
on the mic
because there is definitely like a
buzzing noise in the background let me
see if that helped
that did not help
i think this mic is like too good it's
actually a really good mic but i think
it's too good
i think this mic is like too good it's
actually a really good bike but i think
it's too good